promise will harvest your buddy
jesus donate to christ
deep oh man hey
hey what happened he killed him he
killed him man what i just decided to
help out you know i got some intel and
the bullet just trying to cut them off
and
i'm [ __ ] i just ran right into you
i'm so sorry i was just like i tried to
stop him i tried to cut him up okay
hey hey so you're saying there's there's
people with the terrorists look at me
you're saying they're not alone i think
so all right did you get a
good look at them or not really i was
too busy worrying about lucy
right lucy but i think they went off in
the storm drains
can't be too far ah
who invited you exactly starlight
listen what i did was unforgivable
i'm going to do everything in my power
to renew my light
not just for you but for all the female
people that i've offended renew your
light
you can join the church of the
collective maybe
you're an idiot hey easy on the
religious persecution okay
new girl starlight maybe one day you can
welcome me back into the seven
i know my road is long and hard are you
serious
there is no way you're coming back
there's no need for language all right
enough
we do not have time for this
look i am with you sister but first we
have to go get the terrorist
okay
where you going going to make a contact
who someone who'd help us find a suit
terrorist
who is the contact what is their actual
name
you'll love it no i won't i won't love
it i never love it
no id not a word from him he left us for
dead and now it's like nothing happened
welcome back everyone it's charlie big
surprise they dropped a new trailer for
the boys season two episode one there's
a couple big clips here so we'll break
it down there's a bunch of easter eggs
so if you're new to the channel i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes this
season
it's actually going to be dropping
september 4th so be sure to subscribe to
get everything i'll do a special
giveaway for the boys episodes too
but you start at the beginning here you
probably recognize this scene this
picks up right after the deep's whale
has been eviscerated by butcher and the
boys and homelanders shows up with the
rest of the seven in stormfront looking
for them
because this is after that big news
broadcast and homelander really
really wants to get butcher stormfront
shows up with them here too so this must
be after she's formally joined the team
i love the fact that the deep names the
whale lucy and homelander is just like
what whatever i can't even believe this
like he's just trying to deal
with the deep and he doesn't really care
about what's going on with the whale he
just wants to get to the boys
they have this funny awkward moment
where he goes in for the hug completely
throwing off homelander
like what the hell dude don't touch me
like he's kind of disgusted at the
display of emotion on the deep
the rest of the seven are all reacting
to the whale like oh we can't believe
this this is kind of terrible like a
train can't believe it even black noir
touches his chest there like he's super
sensitive like he's all sad oh no this
is so terrible
like he's mourning the whale like he's a
totally nice dude or an animal lover
underneath that costume when he's not
busy
slicing people up and ripping people's
heads off if you read the boys comic 2
black noir is way way worse but i think
we're all kind of expecting them to
change his character a little bit from
the comics
please be careful about posting black
noir spoilers in the comments because
there are a couple big twists with his
character in the comics that they
haven't revealed in the tv show yet
i'll talk more about black noir during
the season 2 episode videos because
there is a lot more of him running
around doing really cool stuff during
the season 2 episodes
but then starlight figures out that
they're actually after huey and the boys
like she steps in like wait a minute
what's going on here
so she's trying to run interference
because she's fully team
boys during season two but she's also
still a part of the seven
this is all probably before that scene
of homelander ordering her to kill
huey in the storm drains like put your
hands in the air like you just don't
care from that last big trailer
and she has to find a way to help huey
escape and make it
seem like he's doing it on his own so
that homelander doesn't suspect her the
way that starlight is talking to the
deep too
makes it sound like he isn't back on the
seven yet like they've still exiled him
or they replaced him with storm front
i really think the storm front though is
meant to be a replacement for
translucent on the seven because they
haven't replaced him during season one
it gets even more awkward and funny when
he starts apologizing to her again for
what he did during season one and starts
quoting her
talking about this church scripture i'm
going to do everything in my power to
renew my light and she's just like
yeah yeah yeah get on with it whatever
all she cares about is helping the boys
escape from homeland or in the seven and
she just
can't stand what's going on with the
deep here then stormfront steps in and
starts making fun of the deep
for being even douchier like what's your
damage dude did you just join a cult or
something
you're an idiot so it seems like the
deep just cannot catch a break
at all it'll probably be like this for a
while during season two
i know a lot of you have been asking
will the deep turn on the seven and
start helping the boys too just like
starlight
it's always possible that that happens
because there's the other scene with him
in a dive bar with a train looking like
they're both just these two outsiders
from the seven like the other seven
don't care about them homelander doesn't
want to have anything to do with them
then homelander flips just a little bit
again when stormfront stops him from
talking to starlight to move things
along
like she's stepping in trying to help
things along herself he just seems kind
of pissed
so this is probably before they have
their big standoff in that other trailer
scene where they get
super freaky and he starts lasering her
chest up
i talked a little bit about that during
my last big trailer video about the
weird
sexual energy between the two of them
and what their dynamic is like
when she first shows up and how that
changes over the course of season two
the showrunner kind of already explained
what's going on with stormfront and
homelander
homelander can't stand her when she
first shows up but then as she says
during the trailer footage
i'm actually trying to help and he's
like oh really how are you trying to
help
then she kind of explains what her grand
plan is and eventually wins him over
like oh okay i see what you're doing
here i
enjoy this let's get busy so she's kind
of replacing
a lot of the energy that stillwell had
with him during season one but she's not
a figure of authority
so it's just gonna change the dynamic
within the seven and kind of shake him
up a little bit
if we're going by comic book power
levels she'd be more powerful than queen
maeve so they have this really crazy
toxic relationship during season two
that's going to be a lot of fun to just
see spiral out of control
but then the other part of this clip
here is butcher recently coming back to
the boys and then being in the middle of
a standoff as to what they do next now
that they're all wanted by federal
authorities and the whole country is
after them including homelander in the
seven
it's open season on the boys at the
beginning of season 2.
based on what they're saying vaught has
cooked up a cover story completely
blaming butcher for stillwell's death at
the end of season 1
instead of homelander as butcher says
she was already dead when i blew her up
because homelander lasered her pretty
good after finding out she lied to him
and covered up the existence of his
superboy lovechild with butcher's wife
the whole reason that stillwell vaught
vogelbaum giancarlo esposito's character
did that covered up the existence of the
child was to one
try and do some damage control for the
future and hope that the kid wouldn't
turn out as much of a psychopath as
homelander when he grew up
but then two the more corporate side of
vot represented by giancarlo esposito
and stillwell
wanted to ensure that homelander as the
lead of their brand towed the company
line
so in order to keep him as under control
as they could hope to
anytime there's a situation or something
that comes up that could potentially
distract homelander
from doing what vaught wants him to do
they get rid of the problem or
they hide it the other part of this boys
scene here too
is the boys questioning butcher about
where he's been since the end of season
one
remember i said that they actually made
a short movie for the boys that they're
gonna drop
right after the season two finale
that'll explain what he was doing in
that big time gap
but huey's also asking him who he's
going to meet to decide what to do next
and he's kind of taunting huey like
there's no way
you'd ever be able to lead the boys
yourself the person that they're going
to see
might wind up being the legend from the
comics he's actually this information
broker who just knows
everything about superheroes he's kind
of meant to be a parody of stanley
some people think he's a parody of jack
kirby but i still think it's stan lee
he's been around for forever and just
knows everything about superheroes
secrets their weaknesses their
whereabouts
so butcher in the comics uses him all
the time to get info on how to take down
superheroes when he goes out on missions
also carl urban was talking about
butcher during season two
and talking about some comic book
concepts the whole idea is
that butcher is trying to do good things
trying to get rid of these bad
superheroes
but he does things that are just as bad
as them so he's really no
better than the superheroes he's trying
to take down so they raised this big
question like he's trying to get his
wife back and rescue her from the
clutches of vaught
and find out what's going on with this
superboy child but what will his wife
think of
when she finds out all the terrible
things that he's done
in order to do that butcher just
continues to get more and more wtf and
depraved
as the story goes on so it's almost like
he's becoming just as bad
as homelander but it's only going to get
more crazy
and messed up from here i cannot wait to
see all the
terrible terrible things that they do
during season 2.
it's a nice palette cleanser after
getting all the avengers end game the
marvel the big dc stuff
but just a reminder that the season is
premiering september 4th
it'll be the first three episodes
dropping so i'll do a video for that
and then the rest of the episodes will
air weekly so i will be doing
weekly episode videos for most of the
season and right after that happens like
giancarlo esposito a villain during the
boys season 2 we're getting the
mandalorian season 2. we should get a
trailer for that pretty soon as well so
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them but leave all
your video requests for the boys or
dc or marvel videos in the comments
below too while you wait for everything
click here for that last big boys season
trailer and click here for that brand
new wonder woman 1984 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you